[Music]
take one
plus two plus four plus eight and
continue on and on adding the next power
of two
up to infinity this might seem crazy but
there's a sense in which this infinite
sum equals negative one
if you're like me this feels strange or
obviously false
when you first see it but i promise you
by the end of this video
you and i will make it make sense to do
this we need to back up
and you and i will walk through what it
might feel like to discover convergent
infinite sums
those ones that at least seem to make
sense to define what they really mean
then to discover this crazy equation and
stumble upon new forms of math where it
makes sense
imagine that you were an early
mathematician in the process of
discovering that one-half
plus one-fourth plus one-eighth plus
one-sixteenth
on and on up to infinity whatever that
means equals one
and imagine that you needed to define
what it means to add infinitely many
things
for your friends to take you seriously
what would that feel like
frankly i have no idea and i imagine
that more than anything it feels like
being wrong or stuck most of the time
but i'll give my best guess at one way
that the successful parts of it might go
one day you're pondering the nature of
distances between objects
now no matter how close two things are
it seems that they can always be brought
a little bit closer together without
touching
fond of math as you are you want to
capture this paradoxical feeling with
numbers
so you imagine placing the two objects
on the number line the first at zero the
second at one
then you march the first object towards
the second
such that with each step the distance
between them is cut in half
you keep track of the numbers this
object touches during its march
writing down one-half one-half plus a
fourth one-half plus a fourth plus an
eighth
and so on that is each number is
naturally written as a slightly longer
sum
with one more power of two in it as such
you're tempted to say that if these
numbers approach
anything we should be able to write this
thing down as a sum that contains the
reciprocal of
every power of two on the other hand we
can see geometrically that these numbers
approach one
so what you want to say is that one and
some kind of
infinite sum are the same thing
if your education was too formal you'd
write the statement off as ridiculous
clearly you can't add infinitely many
things no human computer or physical
thing
ever could perform such a task if
however you approach math with a healthy
irreverence
you'll stand brave in the face of
ridiculousness and try to make sense out
of this nonsense that you wrote down
since it kind of feels like nature gave
it to you so
how exactly do you dear mathematician go
about defining
infinite sums well practiced in math
that you are
you know that finding the right
definitions is less about generating new
thoughts than it is about dissecting
old thoughts so you go back to how you
came across this fuzzy discovery
at no point did you actually perform
infinitely many operations
you had a list of numbers a list that
could keep going forever if you had the
time
and each number came from a perfectly
reasonable finite sum
you noticed that the numbers in this
list approach one but what do you mean
by
approach it's not just that the distance
between each number and one
gets smaller because for that matter the
distance between each number and two
also gets smaller after thinking about
it
you realize what makes one special is
that your numbers can get
arbitrarily close to one which is to say
no matter how small your desired
distance
one one hundredth one one millionth or
one over the largest number you could
write down
if you go down your list long enough the
numbers will eventually fall within that
tiny tiny distance of one
retrospectively this might seem like the
clear way to solidify what you mean by
approach but as a first time endeavor is
actually incredibly clever
[Music]
now you pull out your pin and scribble
down the definition for what it means
for an infinite sum to equal some number
say x it means that when you generate a
list of numbers by cutting off your sum
at finite points
the numbers in this list approach x in
the sense that no matter how small the
distance you choose
at some point down the list all the
numbers start falling within that
distance of
x in doing this you just invented some
math
but it never felt like you were pulling
things out of thin air you were just
trying to justify what it was that the
universe gave you
in the first place
you might wonder if you can find other
more general truths about these infinite
sums that you just invented
to do so you look for where you made any
arbitrary decisions
for instance when you were shrinking the
distance between your objects
cutting the interval into pieces of size
one-half one-fourth
etc you could have chosen a proportion
other than one-half
you could have instead cut your interval
into pieces of size
nine-tenths and one-tenth and then cut
that right-most piece
into the same proportions giving you
smaller pieces of size
nine one hundredths and one one
hundredth then cut that tiny piece of
size one one hundredth similarly
continuing on and on you'd see that nine
tenths plus nine one hundredths
plus nine one thousandths on and on up
to infinity
equals one a fact more popularly written
as point nine repeating equals one
to all of your friends who insist that
this doesn't equal one and it just
approaches it
you can now just smile because you know
that with infinite sums
to approach and to equal mean the same
thing
to be general about it let's say that
you cut your interval into pieces of
size p
and one minus p where p represents any
number between zero and one
cutting the piece of size p in similar
proportions we now get pieces of size
p times one minus p and p squared
continuing in this fashion always
cutting up the rightmost piece into
those same proportions
you'll find that one minus p plus p
times one minus p
plus p squared times one minus p on and
on always adding p to the next power
times one minus p
equals one dividing both sides by one
minus p
we get this nice formula
in this formula the universe has offered
a weird form of nonsense
even though the way that you discovered
it only makes sense for values of p
between 0 and 1 the right hand side
still makes sense when you replace
p with any other number except maybe for
one
[Music]
for instance plugging in negative one
the equation reads
one minus one plus one minus one
on and on forever alternating between
the two equals one half
which feels both pretty silly and kind
of like the only thing that it could be
plugging in two the equation reads one
plus two
plus four plus eight on and on to
infinity
equals negative one something which
doesn't even seem reasonable
on the one hand rigor would dictate that
you ignore these since the definition of
infinite sums doesn't apply in these
cases
the list of numbers that you generate by
cutting off the sum at finite points
doesn't approach anything
but you're a mathematician not a robot
so you don't let the fact that something
is nonsensical stop you
i will leave this some for another day
so that we can jump directly into this
monster
first to clean things up notice what you
get when you cut off the sum at finite
points
1 3 7 15
31 they're all one less than a power of
two
in general when you add up the first n
powers of two
you get two to the n plus one minus one
which
this animation hopefully makes clear
[Music]
you decide to humor the universe and
pretend that these numbers all one less
than a power of two
actually do approach negative one it
will prove to be cleaner if we add one
to everything
and say that the powers of two approach
zero
[Music]
is there any way that this can make
sense in effect
what you're trying to do is make this
formula more general
by saying that it applies to all numbers
not just those between 0 and 1.
again to make things more general you
look for any place where you made an
arbitrary choice
here that place turns out to be very
sneaky so sneaky in fact that it took
mathematicians until the 20th century to
find it
it's the way that we define distance
between two rational numbers
that is to say organizing them on a line
might not be the only reasonable way to
organize them
the notion of distance is essentially a
function that takes in two numbers
and outputs a number indicating how far
apart they are
[Music]
you could come up with a completely
random notion of distance where
two is seven away from three and one
half is four fifths away from a hundred
and all sorts of things
but if you want to actually use a new
distance function the way that you use
the familiar distance function
it should share some of the same
properties
for example the distance between two
numbers shouldn't change
if you shift them both by the same
amount
so 0 and 4 should be the same distance
away as 1 and 5
or 2 and 6 even if that same distance is
something other than 4
as we're used to keeping things general
the distance between two numbers
shouldn't change if you add the same
amount to both
of them let's call this property shift
invariance
there are other properties that you want
your notion of distance to have as well
like the triangle inequality but before
we start worrying about those
let's start imagining what notion of
distance could possibly make powers of
two
approach zero and which is shift
invariant
at first you might toil for a while to
find a frame of mind
where this doesn't feel like utter
nonsense but with enough time
and a bit of luck you might think to
organize your numbers into rooms
sub-rooms sub-sub-rooms and so on
you think of zero as being in the same
room as all of the powers of two greater
than one
as being in the same sub-room as all
powers of two greater than two
as being in the same sub-sub-room as
powers of two greater than four
and so on with infinitely many smaller
and smaller rooms it's pretty hard to
draw infinitely many things
so i'm only going to draw four room
sizes but keep in the back of your mind
that this process should be able to go
on forever
if we think of every number as lying in
a hierarchy of rooms
not just 0 shift invariants will tell us
where all of the numbers must fall
for instance 1 should be as far away
from 3 as 2 is from 0.
[Music]
likewise the distance between 0 and 4
should be the same as that between one
and five
two and six and three and seven
continuing like this you'll see which
rooms sub-rooms
sub-sub-rooms and so on successive
numbers must fall into
you can also deduce where negative
numbers must fall for example
negative one has to be in the same room
as one
in the same sub-room as three the same
sub sub room
as seven and so on always in smaller and
smaller rooms with numbers one less than
a power of two
because zero is in smaller and smaller
rooms with the powers of two
so how do you turn this general idea of
closeness based on rooms and sub-rooms
into an actual distance function you
can't take this drawing too
literally since it makes one look very
close to 14 and 0 very far from 13
even though shift and variance should
imply that they're the same distance
away
again in the actual process of discovery
you might toil away scribbling through
many sheets of paper
but if you have the idea that the only
thing which should matter in determining
the distance between two
objects is the size of the smallest room
they share
you might come up with the following any
numbers
lying in different large yellow rooms
are distance one from each other
[Music]
those which are in the same large room
but not in the same orange
sub-room are a distance one-half from
each other
those that are in the same orange
sub-room but not in the same
sub-sub-room
our distance one fourth from each other
[Music]
and you continue like this using the
reciprocals of larger and larger powers
of two
to indicate closeness
[Music]
we won't do it in this video but see if
you can reason about which rooms
other rational numbers like one-third
and one-half
should fall into and see if you can
prove why this notion of distance
satisfies many of the nice properties we
expect from a distance function
like the triangle inequality
here i'll just say that this notion of
distance is a perfectly legitimate one
we call it the two attic metric and it
falls into a general family of distance
functions called the p
addict metrics where p stands for any
prime number
these metrics give rise to a completely
new type of number neither real nor
complex
and have become a central notion in
modern number theory
[Music]
using the two attic metric the fact that
the sum of all powers of two
equals negative one actually makes sense
because the numbers 1
3 7 15 31 and so on genuinely approach
negative one
this parable does not actually portray
the historical trajectory of discoveries
but nevertheless i still think it's a
good illustration of a recurring pattern
in the discovery of math
first nature hands you something that's
ill-defined or even nonsensical
then you define new concepts that make
this fuzzy discovery make sense
and these new concepts tend to yield
genuinely useful math
and broaden your mind about traditional
notions so
in answer to the age-old question of
whether math is invention or discovery
my personal belief is that discovery of
non-rigorous truths
is what leads us to the construction of
rigorous terms that are useful
opening the door for more fuzzy
discoveries continuing the cycle
[Music]
you